bonjour madame gagnon bonjour les pays
est-ce qu'ils ont l'obligation de
recevoir des réfugiés qui fuient la
guerre
alors votre question à la fois très
simple et un peu compliqué je vais
essayer de répondre de la manière la
plus simple possible lorsque des
personnes fuient des conflits armés
fuite violence généralisée comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui en ukraine elles
doivent être accueillis dans les pays
limitrophes en l'occurrence et elles
doivent recevoir toute l'assistance à
laquelle elles ont besoin de subtilité
qui peuvent à intervenir mais la règle
c'est la règle du non refoulement qui
est inscrite dans les traités
internationaux qui y est consacré par
tous le droit international qui est
coutumière on ne renvoie pas vers un
endroit où des personnes peuvent
craindre pour leur vie ces personnes si
on peut les accueillir sur son
territoire ouais c'est le bon sens là on
dirait que prévaut et là les pays de
l'union européenne justement ils ont
décidé d'accorder une protection
temporaire aux réfugiés c'est qu'ils
pourront séjourner pendant trois ans à
peu près jusqu'à trois ans il
travaillait à la l'école donc on
s'imagine que c'est pas une obligation
de faire tout ça c'est quelque chose que
l'union européenne a décidé d'offrir
alors en fait il ya une convention qui
elle est universelle c'est la convention
de 1951 et qui donc ça pique au niveau
mondial aux états qui ont signé cette
convention cette convention au premier
chef elle va dire qui a le droit ou
statut de réfugié et une fois que les
personnes en droit au statut de réfugié
elles ont elles ont eu un certain nombre
de droits sur le territoire sur
lesquelles elles ont trouvé refuge le
droit de travailler le 3-2 le droit au
pardon aux soins médicaux peut-être aux
soins médicaux et c'est
simplement ici l'union européenne prend
une mesure dans le cadre de cette
intégration qui est cette communauté
d'états qui est face à cet afflux de
réfugiés sur son territoire aux
frontières de l'europe alors je n'ai pas
lu la directive en tant que tel donc je
peux pas la commenter mais ce qu'on peut
voir c'est que effectivement
théoriquement les réfugiés doivent être
accueillis tous de la même façon et en
l'occurrence si l'union européenne prend
des mesures il ya aussi certainement un
volet politique à ces mesures qui sont
prises et ça fait aussi terriblement
écho à la crise qu'on a appelé la crise
syrienne mais on pourrait aussi
développer là dessus ou l'union
européenne justement a pas tellement
brillé par la manière dont elle accuse
les réfugiés en effet il ya des pays qui
veulent bien accueillir des réfugiés
mais ils veulent surtout et seulement
accueillir ceux qui sont de nationalité
ukrainienne est ce qu'ils sont le droit
de faire cette espèce de distinction le
sol en la nationalité non pas en cas de
la d'afflux massif sur les pays
limitrophes toutes les personnes qui
fuient les persécutions qui fuient la
violence généralisée doivent être
accueillis sur les territoires où elles
peuvent trouver refuge bon au moins ça
c'est clair et là maintenant parlons du
canada qu'est ce qu'on fait nous au
canada on exige un visa c'est ce que
c'est conforme ou aux politiques aux
directives alors là encore théoriquement
on devrait exiger aucun papier d'une
personne qui fuient des persécutions
pour qu'elles puissent se rendre sur un
territoire et qu'elles puissent demander
l'asile sur le territoire sur lequel
elle se rend le l'aspect particulier du
canada c'est qu' il est très loin ouais
de ces zones et que donc pour instruire
les demandes pour vérifier qui il va
accueillir ou pas sur son territoire
bien finalement il a plus de marge de
manoeuvre que la pologne la moldavie la
roumanie qui elles font face à un afflux
massif et dans ce cas là le canada peut
se déployer alors là je ne sais pas
comment ça se passe ça peut se faire
aussi avec le haut commissariat des
nations unies pour les réfugiés mais le
canada peut envoyer des fonctionnaires
dans les pays limitrophes et instruire
des demandes de personnes qui vont
vouloir se rendre au canada mais
théoriquement toutes les personnes qui
fuient des persécutions encore une fois
devrait pouvoir être accueillis sur
n'importe quel territoire où elles
pourraient trouver refuge adam grignon
et à moscou et kiev qui sont entendus
aujourd'hui pour établir des couloirs
humanitaires
le qu'est ce que ça fait c'est un
couloir comment ça fonctionne est ce que
c'est une zone de cessez le feu est ce
que on permet un ravitaillement par ces
corridors des fournitures médicales que
ça comment ça fonctionne alors là encore
il faudrait que j'ai pu lire l'accord
j'ai comme vous videz nouvelle mais je
n'ai pas vu la corse que je peux vous
dire c'est que en droit international
humanitaire il est possible de créer des
zones dans lesquelles on va sécuriser
les civils où toutes les personnes qui
sont hors de combat en droit humanitaire
il y en a au moins cinq catégories de
cette zone qui répondent à des exigences
juridiques différentes donc vous voyez
bien que c'est très difficile pour moi
de commandes a une manière très précise
sur ce qui s'est fait la sq est
simplement absolument fondamental à
retenir c'est que ces corridors
humanitaires dans le passé ils ont
parfois été aussi le prétexte de viser
des populations et demi et ils ont été
le prétexte de commettre des massacres
donc il faut absolument qu'ils aient la
bonne foi des parties au conflit qui
décident de s'entendre pour créer des
zones sûres pour les civils qui doivent
recevoir de l'assistance humanitaire est
l'élément qui est fondamental aussi
c'est que théoriquement on devrait pas
avoir besoin couloir humanitaire parce
que en droit humanitaire les personnes
civiles les personnes hors de combat ont
toujours le droit de recevoir de
l'assistance humanitaire c'est à dire
des vivres et des médicaments selon leur
situation et bien julie à grignan tout
ça est absolument captivant on a tout à
apprendre sur ces questions merci
beaucoup d'avoir partager votre savoir
avec nous merci à vous d'être enterrée
au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]
oh